а топ- 100 вищих навчальних закладів за
кількістю поданих заяв - це такі
навчальні заклади е Київський
національний університет імені Тараса
Шевченка Львівський Франка Львівська
політехніка КПІ ее КНТУ Київський
національноний торгово-економічний
національний авіаційний
Дніпропетровський імені Гончара
чернівецьки імені фетьковича Харківський
імені Каразіна і київський
національй-економічний університет це
найпопулярніші університети на сьогодні
за кількістю поданих заяв
по спеціальностям при вступі на
бакалаврат найпопулярніші спеціальності
знову ж таки не дуже міняється
конфігурація з року в рік це філологія
право менеджмент комп'ютерні науки
середня освіта психологія та економіка
та це знову ж таки досить типовий
перелік
спеціальностей е тому в
принципі який підтверджують тенденцію
популярності тих чи інших спеціальностій
серед
абітурієнтів